hey Samuel eats here and I just want to
apologize on this video because
yesterday we put out a little trailer
for the financial freedom challenge
which is basically I said that when I
hit a hundred thousand subscribers I'm
going to drive to someone's house and
live with them for seven days and
basically help them become financially
free and as it happens I went earlier we
did this in the news last month
put the video together and I said when I
hit a hundred thousand subscribers I'm
gonna I'm gonna release the video we hit
a hundred thousand subscribers yesterday
so especially thank you massively
massively massively for everyone who
subscribed so the video we're going to
put the link up I think in the next 24
hours as a premier and it's going to be
live to watch on our next Monday video
which is going to be 7:00 p.m. on Monday
I am extremely sorry from the bottom of
my heart that we've had made you wait
this long
I know people yesterday we're gonna put
a little trailer out on it we're like
you Samuel just put it out now listen
the reason it's taken a little bit
longer than we hoped to put out it's
just because number one there was a born
into certain bits to be in there some
follow up bits to make sure that the
story was as accurate as possible and
also this is a full documentary that
she's not like a 20 minute video so this
is ain't I said what happened of the
week and it's like an hour and 20
minutes so it's almost like a movie of
me living in someone's house for a week
it was challenging on some really hard
times I didn't expect it to be as hard
as it was and I don't know if I I've got
an image to ever do anything even like
that like I can but what I will say is
that on Monday at 7 p.m. the full things
coming out and there's a lot of lessons
in there for sure so I'm really got
myself to setup often I'm really sorry
folks or sorry for making you wait this
long I am on a hundred thousand is going
to be a next video which is going to be
on Monday thank you for your patience
please do put in your Ironman putting
you die because other than anything like
this before me moving to someone's house
last minute living with them for a week
this person as well
when I went to his house zero money zero
properties zero property experience
ccj county court judgment against his
name no belief serious issues you know
so not just not just but just
emotionally but also physically and it
was an emotional week trying to help
someone like that go into property was
an emotional week but I'll learn loads
and I think you'll too so Monday 7:00
p.m. it's come in put it in your diary
thank you so much for your support and
again sorry to make you wait so long it
will be worth the wait I promise the
documentaries going to be worth the way